we are going to Dallas for New Year's
and we're taking you guys with us
[Music]
all right belief nation so I wanted to
take Nina out of the country go
somewhere hopefully warm to celebrate
New Year's Nina doesn't have a lot of
time off of her nine-to-five job and so
we only have from basically the
frightened to the monday-friday man this
Friday night now filming this so I
thought Dallas because a lot of people
bought my book you're one word in that
las' and there's a direct flight to
Toronto and it's supposed to be worn but
this weekend my Anjali snow so that's
gonna be fun and here we go there is
currently a crazy snowstorm happening
outside here in Toronto so we're gonna
try to catch our uber we get the airport
and hopefully fingers crossed make our
flight check it out
this is the snow who was really coming
down hard but this actually isn't that
bad
let's just hope we can make it to the
airport on time to get to Dallas and get
to more snow how's the uber Nina
completing the TripAdvisor
fifteen minutes all right what are we
gonna do sing tide out a boom da da da
da boom da da da da boom da now lay home
[Laughter]
[Music]
Nina I already
kind of a snobby thing to do but I love
traveling business class so you gotta
stand in line just say it's a
frustration traveled like 13 times or
something this year it's crazy just love
skipping the lines take your picture
Nina smile look at how little you are in
this green don't look at it that's my
turn no such thing as the biggest smile
don't get an X you know don't get an X
okay stop it don't get an X doesn't
matter just a random check yeah I didn't
get it
no X your eyes aren't even open areas
open okay whatever at this imagine
parents Evan come on what xeg4 next to
me I was cheering that for next for you
yeah let me see the smile hold on look
at that
all right let's go we made it through I
remember on our recent shift Nina got
stopped in Paris for having too much
makeup and liquids and perfumes a London
London and that we waited forever they
had to unpack her bags everything but
not this time we made it through and it
didn't bring too much liquid to get
Japanese
London London is more strict okay we're
gonna find our spot and get some food
get some food
all right let's do it food you know
you've been at the airport too many
times when you know the gate and then
you know where all the food is around it
and what your options are
I have been here too many times last 50
years oh and and we're gonna get back on
the first so it's our first trip of the
up next is so what we're gonna do for
food
wall burgers love burgers and Booster
Juice oh you're hungry love burgers huge
wooden went to Tony Robbins we went to
our burgers first and I got Nina huge
you finish it you finished it okay well
then we'll get you net leave em is
little but she can she can eat a lot
where does it go she works it off with
all her thinking Nina got her food she's
excited you want to try one don't you
want to sit down
game fries yam tater tots or sweet
potato tater tots okay Oh Cheers ha
Oh yummy hmm okay those don't mind what
do you think no need I'm oh let me do
that f/64 this is that let's go to
Dallas
there are no seats we waited too long so
we're sitting where the escalator
elephants Taekwon kids to enjoy our
dinner what do you got anything what do
we got
they're really good cinnamon on
okay just here it's posted oft they open
it up and see oh see oh see do hit up
the bun this together
Oh
okay Nina what do you got let's see
barbecue
good there it is there oh that looks
pretty good - looks pretty good too
alright think about joining ago
all right Kenny eat we are enjoying our
awesome burgers they're really good I'm
super greasy but I'm looking for a clay
Susy camera super greasy but amazing we
just found out that our flight is
delayed
fingers crossed this is the only issue
because every time I just pose like
that's what hit me
this is it any minute that means let's
celebrate we're going to get a booster
juice after this yeah
all right celebrate we have 22 minutes
to get some Booster Juice
[Music]
bananas away let's get in chop the kale
all right Cheers Nina boom
sip it up how was it we're gonna try
mine more sweet
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah all right
you like yours now I know what yours is
like it's okay I was gonna say I'm not
gonna try yours because it has Nina
cooties on it but I didn't realize that
she drank mine anyway so it's a bigoted
determinant booties are everywhere all
right fine oh yeah
how's like a milkshake oh it's okay
you know how do you not like this one
Oh distracted by the alcohol distracted
by the you know where you going what are
you looking for Nina what happened
too much freeze brain freeze you know
what you need some alcohol to get rid of
the brain freeze Nina just ran into a
fan I love this guy
give you all the motivational all I need
what's right to master the food a [ __ ]
what do you do Amazon that to be a spit
Cup so fill me by Amazon okay your own
stuff
no well I privately so this guy inspired
me with like seven months ago I ran a
winter feeding business in the summer
okay
and I watch a video and warm up it cause
like all those guys and just like when
we help you my sales stop I have an epic
battle
I stood this guy is not a super fantasy
not my name I don't know where you fight
for buyers okay we're going to we're
going to Dallas for news
oh my god I need like in the background
like ice cream that's okay man okay
basically it's all love I love I love
you Tina but I don't remember your name
that's okay man it's all love it's all
love
I like getting stopped I like interact
with fans neither does too so you stop
me though this time last time in London
Nina got stopped Nina got said are you
Nina
are you mean that member is named Nina
Jake she forgot his name last time
you're never gonna forget now how we
like being stopped especially especially
with Nina what oh the doctor there's a
dog the dog likes you Nina
the dog really likes you Nina
Nina misses team already Nina it's been
like an hour
okay we're gonna wait for our flight now
and George's it's a mix yeah just like
me I'm a mix Nina's not a mix Lena's
pure Chinese I'm a mix I'm half Italian
half British what yeah he's a mix look
he's coming back
there he is Nina
I'd like the ears those are crazy Nina
your ears are crazy too we love you here
if you love Nina's ears leave a comment
and below Nina we love your ears Nina
still can't get enough of this dog it's
six years old [ __ ] she likes to cuddle
with you
schnauzer and yorkshire terrier mix all
Nina wants to do doesn't even want to go
in the plane anymore just wants to do
with this dog same city look at the
years two years about doctors I love the
years I think you should check it with
the late again
other time
no delay
it's like 15
Nina doesn't want to check me she's too
busy taking this dog
dachshund come back
because if I can tailor that
you know you're obsessing his done
huh
she's gonna come back
come back this is really not art blog
anymore it's and dog joke and it's a dog
show
the nagas for neck massage them again
nina is now researching the schnauzer
terrier dogs how come you're doing this
research nina are we gonna get another
dog is that what's happening what about
team oh are you leaving team oh now are
you abandoning team Oh for another dog
oh my god so fun fact about Nina every
night she watches faced with videos
about animal shelter rescue dogs and
them being safe all I hear is
inspirational music it's kind of sad
inspiration was more sadness and
inspiration to be honest it's more sad
and then and then I hear Nina go ah
it's basically every night Yesenia does
how long do you spend watching videos
every night
she spent an hour and a half watching
dog videos rescue videos Nima's one word
is Kara so she's very caring but I feel
like you should do something that's
actually caring not just watching videos
go help dogs or
give the husband a massage on the neck
okay I got to work on my ear hair got a
grill make your hair out so that I can
qualify get neck massages otherwise I'm
interrupting you nose dive time so Nina
made friends with the dog owner
you think the Japanese and they gave her
by the Korean buffet to give us a snack
what happens when you Nina and you make
friends
about dogs what is that okay you try
that looks like I think it's dates date
oh it's a lot softer than thought it's
red Dean
different kind of grain you say thank
you were you nice you say thank you in
Korean
get people in the comments tell us how
to say thank in Korean San Dena can
study up so the next time we run into a
Korean dog owner at the airport and she
gives us their retreat we will be able
to thank her properly the love of dogs
got you a free snack just by being
caring look at that Nina's using her one
word and you know what Nina all of
beneath all I believe nation cares about
you too
why are you laughing it's true you're
gonna get some good comments I think I
think got you a lot of the comments
should be you should give Evan a neck
massage maybe we'll have to give away a
free buck to a random person who leaves
a comment about how I should get a neck
massage from Nina yo hey I'll get a lot
of comments but the comments have to be
around me getting a neck massage from
Nina
and then we'll pick somebody to give a
free book to what do you think Nina is
that a good idea I think I might do it I
think I might do it guys leave that
comment we'll make it happen
so the Chicago flight next to us
we supposedly repeat something they can
the life
and we are going
our flight hasn't come in yet we were
supposed to how many that was this 825
835 initially and then it would became
five now it's 9:05
maybe we'll go celebrate with another
pose
let's hope that's the end we got a good
two dollars we have fans to meet
tomorrow I posted to the my youtube
channel in the comments are filling up
with people who want to show up so we
gotta meet them at the cafe Brazil
tomorrow
so we need to get the balance
many people a lot of just maybe firing
and we have
Boston is proud meanwhile Nina is on the
mobile app for qgg looking at dogs for
sale in Toronto looking at rescue dogs
for us to have I feel like this fight
needs to leave ASAP or we're gonna end
up with four extra dogs who ever get
home cuz Nina's browsing Nina these are
all very cute dogs yeah you can
volunteer to go and look after and pet
and care for but remember we have we
have Teemo and and a husband who needs
neck massages - I don't think she's
listening to me she's lost in the world
of her dogs oh my gosh why do I feel
like we're gonna end up with all eight
of those puppies I went to the bathroom
and found some snacks along the way got
some OMG bites and fuzzy peaches except
that we would never have at home while
we're on our diet but we travel
especially the Dallas we could check out
let's go show Nina hey Nina
I got some snacks too sweet knees a
little sad cuz the dog is gone you want
water I can get you something I'll get
you some water I'll be right back
now if I knew I would have got along
with my snacks but I should have thought
ahead and said hmm maybe need to need
some water
but what a good husband do magic it just
appeared wife can be refreshed mmm drink
that water that's a water commercial you
just like slow motion with stars and
wind behind you and and then you gotta
go ah yeah water it's almost our turn
some people are ready starting to line
up that's where we're gonna be
come on fellas what's the latest update
delay delay delay 9:30 it's unsure what
time yeah well I'm going to join my
snacks and is having her water and
looking up more dogs
we just got sent a really cute picture
of Teemo line back passed out so you
know like that and hopefully hopefully
the third delay is the last delay and
we'll get on the good news is the bike
before us finally took off so we should
be next
what just happened Nina
the lead for the fourth time 12:30 a.m.
you've got to make it to the meet up at
Cafe Brazil what's the good news Nina
minus 34 tomorrow night in Toronto you
know what that is in Fahrenheit so even
though it's gonna be cold in Dallas I am
grateful to not be in the Toronto cold
at least we can get out of here for
another piece of good news I went to bed
last night at 11:00
well 10 we got ready for bed but I kind
of fell asleep postal
and then I got up at 3:00 I woke up at
3:00 and got out of bed closer to four
and then I got a lot of work done it was
pretty awesome
and then when my team came over at 9:00
like I'd only done five hours of work I
already checked off good chunk of the
past
so I felt good and I gotta spend more
time with my team and catch up and do
other special projects it's starting to
hit me a bit now though the lack of
sleep or maybe just the frustration of
waiting but I'm feeling tired but I
don't usually wake up at three
sometimes I've gone to bed as late as
Street I don't usually wake up at three
so I got a lot of work done tonight
happy that's my good news
I feel bad for the kids for waiting here
the flight got delayed multiple times
and they're falling asleep at the table
at least they're behaving they're not
freaking out but I feel bad for them but
they're super tired and getting really
late
what's up become soon
Nina got up and said I want to pass out
and then started [ __ ] towards the
booth I know she's going to do there
they said we're gonna pour it at ten
something and leave at 10:30 it's not
quite boarding time yet I don't know
what she's uh what she's doing there
she's looking you know what if Nina is
close it's gonna make the situation
better that's what I think
what do you guys Oh Dallas
we're waiting for someone to be here
that we've been going Nina we're waiting
for someone to be here that's it that's
what they said you'd look like a giant
from this think of giant Nina I said I
said Nina got up and by walking over
there she's gonna make it better and
then as soon as you got over there they
make the announcement we're just waiting
for someone to be here and then we're
gonna go Nina you made that happen thank
you the whole Dallas flight thanks to
you for your awesomeness
we love you Nina Nina's watch she's
gonna funny
we love her people are coming up people
are coming up that means that our flight
is going to be ready soon it's very
exciting
[Music]
which really means
and the 15 minutes right
the plane is here people are getting up
they are cleaning it up and de-icing it
so we can take off
estimate time of arrival is what 130 and
something like that maybe a late night
what he's passed both of our bedtimes we
are early supers then but it's okay
Happy New Year baby how we celebrate
funny
yeah I'm too excited let's get on the
play
Nina I love you
we're going to Dallas Nina's first ten
the Dallas grinning we're gonna get our
cowboy hat she's already got the boots
on in the jeans cowboy jeans cowboy
boots Chinese cowgirl
[Music]
it's easy
let's cancel this flight so we're just
waiting for a gate agent to come down
and help you guys back up to the up to
the top there and sort of to your travel
arrangements I guess my apologies
there's not much we can do here
came to the flame
figure it out almost made it so even
though we just sat on an airplane we
have to fill out customs because
technically we left Canada so Nina
anything good clear here you go
Nina's a grumpy bear so we sat on the
plane for what a half just to get back
off we're officially in America have to
go through Canadian customs do
everything the Clara Nina nothing if
eclipse I don't know if we're gonna be
able to catch a flight in the morning or
have to cancel our trip they're gonna
give us a piece of paper and tell us
what we've been rebooked on so we'll see
we will see let's go
so coming back to Toronto it's not that
we ever really left I left
comment on the video I feel really bad
to see we're gonna show up tomorrow
I did mention the video hey pay
attention just in case anything happens
but I feel bad cuz some people are gonna
show up and I don't know if we're gonna
you can get to Dallas at all for New
Year's or or what's gonna happen so I
just I'm gonna find a way to make it up
to everybody I don't know what's gonna
happen quite yet stay tuned it's gonna
be a late night but we'll get through it
as we always do life happens
you gotta believe we're sitting here
waiting for our cab Lina's on the call
with Air Canada people I'm hold you
basically either catch up late tomorrow
morning at 8 o'clock
oh we don't go don't know how full that
flight is I bet everybody's trying to
get on that flight you find out a lot of
space and that's the only flight from
Toronto to Dallas tomorrow period he was
gonna see if she can make that happen
we believe in Nina I mean Wow
got some fuzzy peaches
always makes life better
that's some fuzzy peaches in worst case
we celebrate in Toronto I just have to
get back to everybody who might be
coming tomorrow a bunch of people said
yes on YouTube a bunch people said yes
by email I want you to say yes on social
media so regardless if it would go and
not tomorrow I'm going to have to write
to everybody tonight
one by one however long it takes to let
them know what's up which which starts I
mean I'm happy to do it but I'd sucks
for them because I want people showing
up and I'm not there I am coming back to
Dallas in August for a video conference
I'm speaking up the details are on my
home page if you go to the experiences
section so Dallas people will make it up
we'll do it then and I think maybe I'll
do a special hangout for you guys we'll
figure something out I'm not thinking
super clear now but we'll figure
something out for all the people who
have been inconvenienced by this as well
as us so stay tuned we'll let you guys
know thank you for your love and support
[Music]
so we made it back unfortunately Nina
just lost the call we still on hold with
Air Canada the Treader eBook so this is
still going no it stopped we'll see in
the cab ride home and managed the
message most of the people on YouTube
who left comments to let them know that
it's not happening in in whatever nine
hours from now eight hours from now I
stopped to get back in time polynomial
and social so the work continues once
they get inside but that will have fast
internet to do all this work so I'm
grateful for that
hey guys it is 3:14 a.m. I have
officially been up for just 24 hours now
leaving the plane my immediate thoughts
with we're just about the fans the
people were gonna show up all the people
that committed to coming on YouTube and
an email on social media and just trying
to track everybody down and that's all I
could think of and responding people in
the car and coming home as soon as I got
home / just responding to everybody on
email and social and involving Sandra
and my awesome assistant to help get
everybody's names and we're probably
gonna do I'm either gonna since I'm you
know sign books to people I'm gonna come
back and do another event in August
anyway some another chance to do a
meet-up you know I genuinely feel bad
for the people who I hope still just
don't show up but probably will I feel
really bad
but once that was kind of dealt with
once that was off my plate okay I did
everything I could to try to reach out
to these people then it got to okay we
need we need to cancel the Airbnb place
we got to cancel the car and I this is
when the sadness started to seep in
because I realized all these plans that
I made mostly for Nina
it's not gonna happen and there was a
lot of effort and planning that went
into making this New Year's be special
for her and their baby place that I've
rented was this beautiful loft that they
use for photography and sleeps 8 people
and I was super excited to take her
there right to this nice sports car and
the money's gone you know you can't get
that back but it's more the memories
that I wanted to create with her having
a great experience for her and that's
that's not gonna happen this year and so
the the sadness crept in for me there
for her not for me like whatever it
happens I'll get a chance to go back I
can see some of those things but I
really wanted that for her and I was
really really sad I'm working through it
and I'll find another way to make New
Year special and really you know there's
so much to be grateful for even on this
crazy adventure of a day for us spending
the time together eating the junk food
seeing the dog you know it's it's it's
all good and and I'll find a way to make
New Year special and just being together
will be fine
so yeah I'm dealing with that I'm
dealing with that I'm feeling a little
bit better right now but if I filmed
like an hour ago while I was trying to
catch all this stuff I was feeling
really really sad which is strange
interesting because I don't really get
super sad that often so that's good it's
good to lean in on those emotions
sometimes so that's it guys I was hoping
to have a awesome vlog to share with you
and show you all about Dallas but that's
not gonna happen today so I'm just
wrapping up
you missed how I was talking about how
sad I was that you get don't get the
experience all the things that I had
playing for you I was very sad
Muniz in her rope so she's probably not
gonna join us in in this final video but
thank you for joining us on our wacky
adventure when did we leave here six
5:30 5:30 it is now 3:30 almost 3:15 ish
so that's a good chunk of time however
long that is and I've been up for 24
hours I'm the night a long time - yeah
so you're gonna pass it you're gonna die
don't die in the shower
Elena's gonna come in Nina bathtub
Nina's gonna come in we had an adventure
today we got to see that dog we're gonna
eat junk food and we spent time together
and we'll still make it a creek you know
what I've been I've been reading about
Tom Brady and his diet and craziness and
like it makes me wanna I might I might
it might be a different video and my
arms getting tired from holding this
yeah so we might I might I might end up
getting super healthy time bleedy style
but thank you guys for watching that
joining us on our blog what was the
highlight of the past X hours for you
tonight
[Music]
the dog dog is a pretty good highlight
the guy was the diamonds I picked up the
guide dog was a good chunk of this video
but our dog is keator come on
oh she's she really she loves me she
really did like you mm-hmm but all dogs
like you well that's not true a lot of
dogs like you and people like you to
feel like NEMA give her a thumbs up in a
comment and say I love you Mina Doggett
maybe I'm gonna die smartest okay this
whole ending is getting way too long so
thank you guys for watching have a great
close to your weekend maybe see you
nagas Dallas we believe in you we hope
you believe in yourself and whatever you
got a point to the camera it's here what
do you love now you're blowing the kiss
okay we'll see you soon bye bye